[Music]
hello everybody it's seven o'clock here
in the uk very welcome to spend your
breakfast with us here at sky news
568 days since the country first went
into lockdown a scathing report today
reveals errors failings and mistakes by
ministers and the scientific advisors
that cost thousands of lives during the
pandemic we'll be joined today to
discuss this by the cabinet office
minister steve barclay and also david
nabarro from the world health
organization
what we're asking is the organizations
to recognize that the menopause can be
an issue in the workplace
also this morning fighting the tragic
impact of the menopause in the workplace
as estimates say 900 000 women in the uk
have quit their jobs because of it we'll
ask the gynecologist dame leslie regan
what employers can do to help a quarter
to nine and
would you like some fruit on top of your
pores
okay do you want to try it for the first
time
yeah all right
from laying down lyrics to serving up
cereal joined by the rapper professor
green who's helping to fight food
poverty by giving breakfast to primary
school kids in east london that's at 9
45. it's tuesday the 12th of october
the uk's most important public health
failure ever the damning new report
which finds serious errors by ministers
and scientists cost thousands of lives
in the pandemic
we know that some of that scientific
advice was wrong but also that
politicians should have challenged that
advice
a warning from food retailers of price
rises over the coming months following a
deal to keep co2 supplies secure
i'm live in dublin ahead of a very
potentially frosty day with uh uk eu
relations at stake as britain's top
braxton minister prepares to call on the
block to make major changes to the
northern ireland protocol
the la palma volcano continues to cause
damage with emergency services telling
people to take shelter after lava
destroys a cement factory
and exploring the challenges facing the
economy as we come out of the pandemic
sky news launch is the first in a series
of live in-person big ideas events
around the country
and truth justice and the quest for
inclusivity dc comics reveals the latest
incarnation of the man of steel
is bisexual
[Music]
that made you sit up and listen didn't
it a very good morning to you one of the
uk's most important public health
failures ever
that's the verdict of a damning new
report which says thousands of lives
were lost at the start of the covid
pandemic due to delays and mistakes made
by ministers and their scientific
advisors it pinpoints decisions on going
into lockdown too late and how care home
residents were exposed the government
says throughout the pandemic it's been
guided by the scientific and medical
experts and never shied away from taking
quick decisive action our science and
technology editor tom clark reports
on a wall opposite westminster 150 000
hearts commemorate those lost to covid
and today's report from mps lays plenty
of criticism for our pandemic failures
at government's door
but it blames the science too
we know that some of that scientific
advice was wrong but also that
politicians should have challenged that
advice
and there is never 100 certainty
with scientific advice so you can't just
say we're following the science you have
to dig down and ask why scientists are
saying what they're saying
that challenge should have happened
earlier the report finds that decisions
on lockdowns and social distancing
during the early weeks of the pandemic
rank as one of the most important public
health failures the country has ever
experienced
specifically it criticizes the dominance
of herd immunity as an idea saying the
uk made a serious early error in
adopting this fatalistic approach
it highlights the failures in test and
trace and protecting social care which
had devastating and preventable
repercussions for people receiving care
in their families
there's plenty of criticism to share
around in this report between
westminster and the scientific advice it
was given but in terms of lessons
learned there are positives too
take the nhs and how flexible it was in
coping with the burden of disease but
also how it pioneered new research into
covid and of course there's all those
vaccines
so far kovitt jabs have saved at least
120 000 lives and the nhs proved it
could adapt to save thousands more one
of the good things i think that's come
out the pandemic is we've demonstrated
that the national health service is the
most agile institution in the united
kingdom the nhs has survived but in a
very broken fashion and the people who
will suffer will be the people who
united of the united kingdom
the object of this report say mps is to
learn lessons so we're prepared for the
next global pandemic
but ensuring we've recovered from this
one will have to come first
tom clark sky news
well the cabinet office minister and
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
steve barkley is with us now hello good
morning thank you for joining us um i
suppose you want to start with an
apology to the british public
uh well um we moved quickly in response
to the vaccine obviously this report has
just come out so we want to look at it
and consider it that's why we've also
got an inquiry to ensure that where
there are lessons to learn we do so but
we followed throughout the scientific
advice
we got the vaccine deployed extremely
quickly we protected our nhs from the
surge of cases but of course if there
are lessons to learn we're keen to do so
keen to start with an apology though i
would have thought oh well no we
followed the scientific advice
we followed the scientific advice we
protected the nhs we took the decisions
based on the evidence before us but of
course we've always said with something
so unprecedented as the pandemic there
will be lessons to learn we're keen to
learn them that's why we've committed to
an inquiry
and that will be the opportunity to look
at what could be done differently and
what lessons we take into the future 20
000 lives needlessly lost because you
didn't lock down a week earlier and you
don't want to apologize well the issue
of the timing of the lockdown was based
on the evidence and the scientific
advice at the time the concern was if
we'd lock down too soon
there wouldn't be a willingness to lock
down for a long period of time now we
actually know now that actually there
was a willingness of the british public
to lock down for far longer than we
envisaged but that reflects the
unprecedented nature of the kobe
pandemic the fact that we know with
hindsight different things to what we
knew at the time but it's right okay
that we look
in the inquiry at what lessons there are
to learn
and ensure that we learn from them no
apology that um we were told by the then
health secretary that there was a
protective ring around uh care homes and
we know that that not to be the case
well the decisions were taken on the
evidence and the scientific advice at
the time they were taken to protect the
nhs the understanding of issues such as
asymptomatic infection and how that
spread the disease we now know far more
about that than we did in 2020 at the
start of the pandemic so i think the
question for the inquiry will be what
information did the government have on
something that was unprecedented were
the decisions informed by the science at
the time
and do we now know
different things about the pandemic to
what we knew in february in 2020 and of
course we've learned a huge amount but
we did take decisions to move quickly
that is why the vaccine was deployed at
pace that was a success that the report
recognizes but this report only
obviously came out at midnight i'm very
keen to read it but we're going to have
an inquiry to look at the lessons to
take forward to the future um
you just took at face value what the
scientists said and didn't challenge
them no i think there was rigorous
debate within government with
science but of course it was
unprecedented so it was a developing
picture for the scientists themselves
there were areas where i think the
government has received credit for
moving very quickly such as with the
vaccine
deployment we also move very quickly to
protect the nhs we all recall the scenes
in italy where its health service came
under massive strain
and we were very keen to avoid our very
own earlier for reasons we were very
keen to avoid that happening to uh
nhs it was an unprecedented pandemic k
we were learning about it as we went
through and of course with hindsight
there's things we know about it now that
we didn't know at the time but we'll
look at the report from the health
select committee and see what lessons
can be taken from i suppose my viewers
this morning will find it difficult to
comprehend that you sent um uh care home
residents back
to their care homes from hospital when
you knew that they had covered and you
didn't test
care home workers well as i say we're
going to have an inquiry to look at
lessons
the principal concern at the time was
around the surge of patients on the nhs
the concern
around delayed discharge
and how that would block up the capacity
of the nhs the understanding around
asymmetric infection was very different
we didn't have the testing regime that
we now have that had to be built from a
standing start so of course k there are
going to be lessons to learn that's why
we've committed
to an inquiry but the government took
decisions at the time based on the
scientific advice it received but those
scientists themselves were operating in
a very new environment where they
themselves were learning about the
pandemic i don't understand why you
don't want to apologize well there are
lessons to learn but the point is that
we took decisions based on the science
we protected the nhs we got the vaccine
deployed at pace but we accept whether
our lessons
we're keen to do so yeah but you're
representing the government this morning
and there were 20 000 unnecessary deaths
in the united kingdom many of them
elderly people and you don't want to
apologize what i'm saying kay is did we
take decisions based on the scientific
evidence we were protected what did we
say
sorry did we save lives through
deploying the vaccine at pace far
quicker than many comparable countries
did we protect the nhs from the surge
that had overwhelmed other health
systems yes we did now were there
consequences to those decisions
and what was the scientific advice we
received and did we make the right
decisions these are legitimate questions
for the inquiry to get into the report
you're talking about came out at
midnight i've not had an opportunity to
read it i'm keen to do so but this is
why we have committed to inquiry so we
can get the lessons on that one fact 20
000 needless deaths according to the
report you don't need to go through the
whole you know hefty report in order to
know that they it says that 20 000
people died needlessly many of them
elderly and infirm
are you not sorry about that well this
is why we're taking decisions for
example around social care
well there will be lessons and of course
where there's lessons we're keen to take
that on board the question you're asking
is in february march of 2020
did we make logical decisions based on
the advice we received and the knowledge
we had at that point on things like
asymptomatic infections was very
different to what we know now now we've
taken on board those lessons that's why
for example we've said that
people need to be vaccinated if they're
working in social care it's why
throughout the pandemic we had funding
packages of support such as the
infection prevention control that went
into social care it's why for example we
applied 11 000 ipads so we could get
better data on exactly what was
happening within the social care sector
but the fundamental point within your
question is are there lessons for us to
learn from what happened at the pandemic
and the answer to that is we will learn
the lessons that's not my question with
respect what i'm saying is that 20 000
families watching this morning probably
um lost a loved one
they couldn't go to the funerals because
either they weren't allowed at all or
that there was an extended family and
they couldn't all go
and we saw
a young man who was lowered into the
ground and his family couldn't be there
and they had to watch it on zoom um
twenty thousand times that happened
needlessly
how can you not say you're sorry well
that is heartbreaking that impact on
families that impact uh in terms of
people's funerals is heartbreaking and i
think all of us feel like all of us have
friends and neighbors who were in that
situation i think in terms of the
decisions that the government take which
is what this report is referring to
there were decisions we took on the
vaccines to protect the nhs based on the
knowledge we had at that point which
were logical decisions for the
government to take but we're keen to
learn from that period it was an
unprecedented time we were working with
imperfect information and it's important
we take those inquiries and that's why
we've got an inquiry to look at that and
was it logical to spend 37 billion
pounds on a test and trace system that
didn't work well just a minute ago you
were saying that we should have done
more to understand asymmetric testing
that will
no doubt be one of the factors in terms
of what happened in social care because
it was the asymptomatic infections that
played such a big part in the fatalities
that we saw in the social care sector
that is exactly why from a standing
style we built a test and taste capacity
obviously that took a huge amount of
effort and cost indeed it did a huge
amount of cost but on the one saying it
was pointless it was it was it wasn't
fit for purpose is are they just
basically um you know coming up with
this report with 2020 hindsight and it
easy for them to say well firstly i had
a chance the report came out at midnight
so another chance to read it so
obviously i will need to do so secondly
i think if you speak to the leading
medical advice in that country they will
not say that test and trace was
pointless in fact they will say it's a
key part of our armory
which is what i'm putting to you
i'm saying if you speak to the chief
medical officer if you speak to the
leading medics within our country they
will not say that test and trace is
pointless they will say it is an
important part of the uk's controls
against a repeat of what happened in our
care homes you can't on the one hand say
that we were wrong not to have controls
around people going into care homes and
on the same time say that we were wrong
to put in control i'm not saying
this is what the report is i'm just
pointing out what i'm saying i'm just
going into the contradiction in the
question between on the one hand saying
it's wrong so you're saying that the
report um is is benefiting from 2020
well the report came out at midnight
i've not had a chance no but you knew
you were on the telly this morning so
i'm sure i'm sure that your aides have
pointed out the highlights for you so
well i'm keen to read it i know we will
engage with it and the inquiry i'm sure
will consider the points that are in it
what you're saying is that the report
thinks that test and trace is pointless
that is not what they said was it was 37
billion pounds was a waste but it was
hugely expensive and as a former
treasury minister i absolutely
recognized it was very expensive but
value for money at a time a national
crisis changes and we were doing
everything we could in order to put in
controls so we could better protect
people and learn from the early lessons
of the pandemic okay let's let's move on
to brexit should we an area that you
know an awful lot about um
the eu it would appear actually uh
giving in and offering up some changes
that they say they have been working on
for some time to try and sort out the
log jam with the northern ireland
protocol to make trade easier lord frost
giving a speech in lisbon i think uh
later on today saying it's not good
enough we've not actually heard what
they're going to say yet well he's
giving a speech obviously um i don't
want to preempt that but i don't see it
as the eu giving it or one side giving
it i think there's a recognition on both
sides that the protocol needs to work
for both communities in northern ireland
the whole underpinning of the good
friday agreement which both sides are
deeply committed to
is based on the consent of both
communities and i think there's a
recognition on both sides that the
protocol is not working and so what law
trust will be talking about is very
sensible proposals that the british
government set out through our command
paper
as to how we can better
ensure that the protocol is fit for the
purpose and sustainable in a long-term
way
is it trade that we're worried about
sausage wars as it's um as it's been
used as shorthand in in many of the
newspapers or is it uh the involvement
of uh the european courts them
overseeing the protocols in in northern
ireland that we're most concerned about
as a country well it's both i think the
governance because we were told it was
trade wars for a long time weren't we
and now we were hearing about the
european court no it's both i think it's
it's both in terms of how trade and
businesses are affected but it's also
the governance as well and the imbalance
of that
but more fundamentally it's about both
communities viewing the protocol as
sustainable in the long term and i think
that's the issue because that really
goes back to what i think shapes the
views of both sides both sides are
committed to the good friday agreement
both sides want to ensure that that is
protected and we need a protocol that is
sustainable in the long term and that's
really what lord frost will be
addressing today and just a quick
thought i know you've got to go um
quite a few um supermarkets and food
production companies are warning that
people shouldn't panic by and uh there
are some concerns about what's going to
happen ahead of christmas and the
shelves are going to be empty in
supermarkets i suppose you would
reiterate their comments that i would i
would and i think people should just
remember the start of the pandemic when
our supply chains came along with a huge
strain and they saw the resilience of
the uk retail sector the government is
working very closely with industry we
brought to dave lewis the chief exec
former chief exec of tesco
into the heart of government to liaise
with the industry we're responding to a
number of industry requests and we do
have an extremely resilient uh food
sector within the uk and what happened
with petrol was driven by a consumer
reaction there's actually more
deliveries than sales going into full
courts that has stabilized but we are
working very actively with industry and
people like dave lewis is helping with
that liaison yeah prime minister
enjoying a few days away at the moment
with his young family you must be quite
envious you've not had a break this year
well it's quite right the prime minister
given that i think all of your viewers k
would recognize the job of prime
minister is a hugely demanding one and i
think people recognize that it's also
important that our leaders our prime
minister uh is able to get refreshed and
come back to the parliamentary term uh
next week i don't think people will
consume that no i'm not saying that i'm
just saying you must be a little tiny
bit envious given that you've not had a
break but i think the demands of a prime
minister are extremely hard and and it's
quite right that he hasn't read okay
it's good to talk to you thanks so much
for joining
thank you and just a reminder if you
want to catch up on any of that
interview or watch the program when
you're out and about this morning then
of course you can you can find us on the
mobile app or you can go to our website
and go into our live blog to watch the
programme and you can catch up on the
interviews on my twitter feed as well
that's at k burley
now there's a warning this morning from
the british retail consortium that food
prices could rise off the back of a deal
to sir to secure co2 supplies until
christmas just to talk about that with
the minister
charlotte lomas is in west london and
joins us now hello to charlotte a very
good good morning what sort of concerns
are the way you are this morning
good morning okay well retailers have
welcomed that deal broker by the
government to secure
co2 supplies until after christmas but
they are also highlighting there's just
another cost pressure for them among
many that they're experiencing at the
moment this should of course be one of
the biggest and best time for the high
street as we approach christmas but
instead they're really a feeling
retailers the impact of labor shortages
of the energy crisis and of course the
issues with the supply chain and there's
a warning that it's going to start
filtering through and that consumers
might start feeling the impact of that
with a warning as you say kay from the
british retail consortium who've carried
out a survey among its members and three
of five retailers now are saying they're
expecting to have to increase prices
over the coming months and this comes
also as consumer confidence has slumped
we know from the british retail
consortium that it's been the weakest
performance this september since january
and that was when the uk was
experiencing heavy lockdown restrictions
so they are really the retailers are
asking now the government to really
expand the scope and size of the new
visa scheme uh to try and help in the
short term
okay charlotte thank you thanks a lot
uh also talking with the minister about
the government's top brexit aide who is
expected to say today that the
arrangement made in january 2020 between
the uk and the eu around northern
ireland needs significant change if it's
to be sustainable minister wouldn't talk
about it in much detail stephen uh
standing by for us uh this morning hello
to you stephen so what's being discussed
what is the eu going to do about it
hi kay well i mean you heard fairly
soothing and restrained words there from
steve barkley although he didn't want to
preempt this speech so essentially uh
lord frost david frost uh britain's top
brexit minister is giving a speech in
lisbon and portugal later on this
afternoon in which he's expected to
outline britain's demands for major
changes and major concessions from the
european union over the controversial
northern ireland uh protocol that's
caused a lot of angst and anxiety here
in dublin and in the other european
capitals as well because maro sekovic
who's the vice president of the european
commission is due tomorrow to outline at
least four different uh ranges of
concessions or compromises that the
european union feel will address all the
concerns from the british side and from
the unionist side in northern ireland
over the working of the protocol as well
so they see the british as essentially
shifting the goalposts that's the phrase
that simon copeland who's the irish
foreign minister used i mean it doesn't
set a great uh background for this
week's events when we saw over the
weekend simon coveney and david frost
sniping at each other on twitter uh
simon kobe taking to twitter at 11
o'clock on a saturday night to say that
the uh questioning whether the uk
government even wants to have a deal
at all so here's a quick reminder about
uh what all of this is about as many of
you will remember during the post-brexit
trade talks the northern ireland border
with the republic of ireland was a major
bone of contention
a major difficulty and the northern
ireland protocol was brought in in the
eventual agreement to try and deal with
that it allows for goods to move freely
between northern ireland and the
republic of ireland avoiding any kind of
a hard border on the island but the eu
customer will still apply in northern
ireland and article 16 then which we're
going to hear a lot about is part of the
protocol and it allows the uk or the eu
to suspend aspects of the protocol if
either side and this is the technical
language considers that it is causing
economic societal or environmental
environmental difficulties or diversion
of trade but of course this should only
be used as a very much as a last resort
and in the face of serious problems when
both sides are unable to agree on a
joint approach to solving those sort of
issues and if one side does go ahead and
trickle trigger article 16 the other
side can take rebalancing action in
response in
in real in real terms neither side
really wants to go down that route and
certainly up until now sources in the
irish government here always firmly
believe that the british government does
want to get some sort of a deal it's
just that they're very very good at
hiding it because essentially the
british approach to these negotiations
has always been a bit more unpredictable
a bit more wild card than the eu's
traditional plotting and methodical
approach so it's budget day here in
ireland plenty of distractions but the
government will be keeping a very close
eye as they win in brussels as well on
what lord frost says in portugal later
this afternoon stephen you started um
your report there by uh giving us a very
big sigh just how frustrating is is the
situation for the people in dublin and
wider island
he's a very calm rational diplomatic
kind of man i was listening to him uh
into being interviewed on national radio
here uh yesterday morning he could
really sense that kind of if i'm saying
he was certainly saying and uh that
frustration if it's that evidence
emanating from simon coveney just give
you a little bit of an insight into the
frustration felt here in dublin and
presumably many of the other uh eu 27
capitals as well okay simon thanks simon
forgive me stephen thank you very much
indeed thank you stephen
um what else is coming up on the
programme for you this morning half past
seven speaking to a driving school boss
about the backlog causing hundreds of
thousands of learners
to wait up to half a year to take their
test
7 45 speak to a former un assistant
secretary general who was stationed in
kabul about the g20 meeting due to take
place today to discuss the situation in
afghanistan
[Music]
at five past eight speaking to the
shadow financial secretary to the
treasury that's james murray to get
labour's view on the report into the
lessons learned from the government's
handling of the pandemic
now people living on the island of la
palma have been told to remain indoors
after the volcano which has been spewing
lava and ash for almost a month engulfed
a cement plant the destruction of the
plant
was
highlighted here on sky news yesterday
volcano has so far destroyed nearly 600
hectares of land and more than one
thousand buildings
six thousand people have been evacuated
from their homes
let's take a look at some of the other
stories making headlines for you this
morning the president of cop 26 says
world leaders must deliver on their
promises to curb dangerous climate
change at the talks in glasgow in a
speech later today alok sharma will call
for leaders to honour the paris
agreement which committed countries to
trying to limit global temperature rises
to less than 1.5 degrees celsius in
order to keep the girl alive
and looking at our climate dashboard you
can see that
according to our scientists it's going
to be 11 years the time left to try to
make sure
that the global temperatures since
1883 do not reach one and a half degrees
higher and we're using 45 percent
of fossil fuels in our retail
power mix
this morning
and a reminder you can get all the
latest on this guy news daily climate
show which airs every weekday evening at
6 30.
at least two people have died and
another two were injured when a small
plane crashed in a residential area of
san diego witnesses say an elderly
couple were rescued from a home in the
suburb of santi while at least three
other homes sustained significant damage
it's not known whether plane was headed
or how many people were on board
latest unemployment figures and the
number of uk workers on payrolls rose by
207 000 between august and september to
a record 29.2 million which um is back
to levels seen before the pandemic
struck that's according to figures from
the official uh office i should say for
national statistics
later today sky news will launch the
first in a series of in-person events
big ideas live bringing together our
specialists key stakeholders and
regional communities to discuss the
pressing issues of our time this week
we'll focus on jobs and the economy
our business presenter ian is up in
rotherham for us hi ian good morning
bright and early uh so tell us what the
plan is for where you are this morning
hello k yes uh welcome from the magnus
science park here at uh the old temporal
burst steel works in rotherham where
we're hosting the first event as you
described it sky news big ideas live now
this is the first in what is described
as a series of thought leadership events
where we're going to be trying to
get our arms around and tackle some of
the big issues of the day and as you
said the focus here is all about jobs
my program in king live will be uh
coming from here live at 10 o'clock this
morning in front of a live invited
audience of business people academics
and other people who are interested in
the economic recovery we'll be
discussing how we create jobs post
pandemic how the uk fires up its economy
gets the best out of the recovery as
possible we'll also be looking at the
opportunities provided by the transition
away from fossil fuels green jobs and
we'll also be talking about
a specific focus here on the north of
england as well and the kind of role
that the north of england is going to
play you may recall of course george
osborne the former chancellor used to
talk a lot about the northern powerhouse
it kind of died away when he and david
cameron left office really so we're
trying to explore that as well we've got
a host of big names coming to join us
for example i'll be joined by uh the
boss of siemens uk carl ennis and lord
billamoria the president of the cbi
later on we'll be hearing from mark
carney the former governor of the bank
of england and as i say there will be
lots of audience participation here live
viewers can hope get involved as well
viewers at home uh by getting in touch
on uh
sky news big ideas live hashtag big
ideas live they can send in their
questions to our panelists and uh we
will be dipping in and out throughout
the day here on sky news there'll be
coverage as i say at 10 o'clock this
morning and then later on at 11 30 and
the whole thing will be streamed live on
sky's various digital platforms as well
so lots of exciting things going on here
today and lots of opportunities for the
viewers at home to get involved as well
okay lovely thanks so much indeedy and
thanks for mentioning mark carney that
our uh colleague sam washington
interview interviewing him uh later on
this morning be able to see that here on
sky news as ian was saying the big ideas
live will be streamed on the website
and social channels throughout the day
and you can get involved yourself if
you'd like to by submitting questions to
the panels using that hashtag as ian was
saying big ideas live
now could the first rocket launch from
the uk be fast approaching
sky aura has signed a deal to blast off
rockets like this
from shetland it's a multi-launch deal
over the next decade which could send
satellites into orbit from 2022. it's
hoped the spaceport on shetland would
create an additional
140 jobs once operational is it going to
go up
[Music]
maybe
hundreds of thousands of learner drivers
talking about them they are having to
wait up to half a year to sit their test
because of delays caused by the pandemic
going to be speaking to a driving school
boss after the break
[Music]
hello everybody um a damning cross party
report uh from mps this morning says
thousands of lives were lost due to
delays and mistakes made at the start of
the coveted pandemic by both ministers
and indeed their scientific advisers
earlier i was joined by the cabinet
office minister steve barkley i asked
him if he'd like to apologize on behalf
of the government for all of the
unnecessary deaths i will listen to what
he said
we followed throughout the scientific
advice
we got the vaccine deployed extremely
quickly we protected our nhs from the
surge of cases but of course if there
are lessons to learn we're keen to do so
keen to start with an apology though i
would have thought oh well no we
followed the scientific advice we
presented
we followed the scientific advice we
protected the nhs we took the decisions
based on the evidence before us but of
course we've always said with something
so unprecedented as the pandemic there
will be lessons to learn
um tamara's here tomorrow i think i i
gave him the opportunity at least eight
times to apologize yes i counted eight
times and the response from steve
barkley was essentially that he will get
around to reading it the government will
take what these two committees the
health and science committees of the
house of commons both chaired by
conservative mps incidentally they will
take it on board and when we have that
full public inquiry that the prime
minister has promised next spring which
we're going to hear from the bereaved
families and we're going to hear in a
lot more detail about what happened at
every stage the government will take
this into account but i think what
really came through is this is the first
proper full assessment of what went
wrong they interviewed all the key
players matt hancock dominic cummings
people who were in number 10 in the room
at the time these decisions were being
taken and what really comes through is
that they feel that although it's not
pointing the finger at any individuals
this isn't an individual sort of call to
resign moment the whole system failed
they didn't challenge some of the
scientists advice they didn't look down
early enough and particularly that
protective ring about around care homes
was not what they say what happened and
it doesn't seem that the government
wants at this stage to take any
responsibility for any of those failings
and i'm sure people who were affected by
that watching the interview and will
have found that very jarring i'm sure a
lot of people watching this morning
would have been throwing things at the
telly when i offered the opportunity to
apologize just we apologize for the loss
of life we didn't get an apology yes and
steve barkley says of course there were
lessons to learn he points out we've
gone a lot of this is an old ground that
we've raked over before why did we not
lock down earlier last march because the
government thought that if you did it
too early then the public wouldn't
comply with it and we now know that
people did comply with it very well over
a long period so as he says we live and
learn but boris johnson said last summer
that he took full responsibility for all
the decisions made during the pandemic
his minister today didn't seem to want
to get into some of the government's
failings which are very glaring in this
report the report says that this was one
of the worst public health failures the
uk has ever seen and there is an immense
amount to learn from it which needs to
be learned right now because we're still
in the pandemic and we may face another
one in the not too distant future and
sorry seems to be the hardest word
thanks very much tomorrow tomorrow's
take at nine o'clock this morning thank
you now uh let's uh move on to do you
remember when you took your test do you
remember when you took your test i took
i took quite a few tests actually okay
did you how many did you check oh maybe
about five what did you did you really
over a longish period wow okay
um i don't know what to say
just move on equality's lie elsewhere
anyway people who are waiting to take
their tests some 400 000 uh having to
wait up to six months to take those
tests due to a backlog caused by the
pandemic joined now by the chief
executive of red driving school that's
ian mcintosh mr mcintosh thank you very
much indeed for joining us on the
programme this morning just how bad is
it for learner drivers at the moment
good morning uh yes it's that's quite a
challenge isn't it to uh to potentially
have to wait that long for a test but i
would argue that you plan ahead here and
you work with your driving instructor to
a program uh and book your test in
advance uh there is a chance then that
you might pass first time and it won't
be a problem at all but it is a huge
problem that there is such a big backlog
and i know the dvsa are doing a number
of things to try and reduce that backlog
what's caused it
uh well the problem is that we were shut
down for uh something like there were no
driving lessons for over 250 days it was
even longer uh in terms of no testing uh
and and there are 2 000 new 17 year olds
every day entering the market in effect
so there's this constant demand for
lessons and for driving tests and uh of
course there was no testing going on
during
those three lockdowns that we had during
2020 so uh it's hardly surprising that
there is a big backlog the challenge now
is how does the industry overcome this
backlog and get back to something like
a reasonable weight for a test
which was going to be my next question
what's the answer
well um it's a little bit up to the dvsa
in a sense i know they're trying a
number of things they're they're
planning to shave five minutes off the
test hopefully by not reducing the
standard of the test but they're trying
to buy back um time from examiners uh so
that they don't go on holiday so buy
back leave they're using all qualified
examiners in their business or in that
their organization that perhaps normally
don't do driving tests so that will add
a bit more capacity they're recruiting
and training more examiners but that
will take time and they're hoping to
move to eight tests a day per examiner
but that's been resisted a little bit by
the public sector union but thankfully
thankfully we've just avoided a strike
which would have been today and
yesterday by the psu so that's um
still to be negotiated i think that
change hasn't happened yet but the dvsa
are working hard to try and deal with
that backlog although of course i'm not
a spokesman for the dvsa but this is
what i've been told
so kids who are turning 17 today parents
as well watching this morning what sort
of advice would you give to them i
remember when my son turned 17 he'd
already um applied for his um test that
would be uh his his um theory test
came on his 17th birthday so he could
then apply for his other test after that
once he'd passed it's quite a complex
route isn't it for young people
uh it is but uh you know lives are at
stake and we we don't want anybody on
the road who's not properly qualified
and especially not our youngsters i'm
sure uh none of us wants our children to
to wing the test pass it and find
they're not actually capable of driving
safely so it's important that we do this
properly
my advice certainly would be
uh to to plan with an instructor your
journey don't apply for a test on one of
these cancellation websites and then
expect somebody to take you to the test
because you're not going to find anybody
the industry is super busy we've never
been busier so plan ahead with an
instructor plan that date in your diary
and work towards it
and of course do all you can to make
sure that you go to that test test ready
that is also good advice from the dvsa
they are saying please bring candidates
to test who are test ready because if
you pass then you don't have to worry
about the backlog if you fail you might
have a long wait for a reset so plan
ahead and prepare properly okay what are
your top tips for uh passing first time
we just i don't know if you heard that
tamara saying that she'd taken her test
five times
yes uh well i don't know the
circumstances of her situation but you
know the test the training is designed
to make people competent safe drivers so
there are fewer maneuvers these days
it's all about following that sat nav
for 20 minutes and demonstrating you're
a safe driver the only way you're going
to do that confidently is lots of
practice lots of training so it becomes
automatic like it is for us experienced
drivers you you hardly think about
driving when you're driving that's the
state of mind you need to get to
if you do that you'll wing the test no
problem at all okay did you pass the
first time yourself
well i didn't but it was a long time ago
to go there i passed second time i think
it was
1976 or something like that okay i took
my test in
1978 i think
for your pastors yeah i passed first
time just saying
it's nice to talk to you thank you so
much for joining us mr mcintosh this
morning thank you
thank you
the only test i ever passed now cast
your minds back to when the silver
screen brought us one of the most famous
incarnations of the last son of krypton
[Music]
excuse me
well the latest incarnation of superman
uh will be bisexual in a future comic
book john kent the son of clark hunt and
lois lane will fall for a reporter named
jay in what dc comets is calling a bold
new direction those working on the
characters say they feel honored to see
that the man of steel is now standing
for something more than hope truth and
justice
there are so many people reaching out in
so many different languages saying what
this means to them you know i'm seeing
tweets of people saying that they burst
into tears when they read the news um
that they wished
that superman was this when they were
growing up that they could see
themselves and people saying for the
first time ever they're seeing
themselves in superman something they
never thought was possible
further now g20 meeting due to take
place today to discuss the situation in
afghanistan
we're going to be speaking to a former
un assistant secretary general in just a
moment
[Music]
hundreds of thousands of people have
been displaced and are affected and most
of them of course are living in uh awful
uh conditions and hence the appeal from
iom the international organization for
migration um in respect of the types of
stories that we are hearing um from idps
as you can imagine as internally
displaced persons they've lost
absolutely everything having to flee
their homes and found themselves in
these unimaginable circumstances many of
them living
in dilapidated
settings um i was in tigre earlier this
year and you had thousands of people
living in schools disused buildings and
some sleeping out in the open and
exposed obviously to all the elements of
changing weather et cetera et cetera and
so the testimonies that we hear from the
idps are extremely uh difficult and sad
uh stories many of the settings in which
they are living in um can no longer be
sustained or the resources are running
out to maintain um those um settings so
for instance what you have is uh people
huddled in in very small and cramped
place places um there is very little
access to water and sanitation obviously
people need access to
clean water to to showers to keeping
clean there is an issue around access to
health services we have situations of
pregnant and lactating women children
obviously who need nutritional help
and support and also the psychological
and emotional impact of the crisis the
21 million dollars that irm the
international organization
for migration is appealing for only is
to respond to the urgent need for new
shelter and relocating internally
displaced people from some of the very
difficult and dilapidated settings
they're in to new shelter now iom has um
in the last few weeks been able to
relocate around 3 000 families but it is
it is very far from addressing the whole
crisis um earlier in the year in july
iom uh we launched an appeal for around
70 million uh us dollars and most of the
funds that we need still have not been
met
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms
human beings directly depend on
underground water source so a lake or a
pond is necessary to replenish these
groundwater resources
[Music]
un secretary general antonio gutierrez
has warned that afghanistan is facing a
make or break moment ahead of a special
summit of a group of 20 major economies
later today to discuss the situation in
the country
italy holds the rotating g20 presidency
this year and the prime minister has
called the meeting in an effort to get
the international community to set a
strategy to prevent afghanistan becoming
a haven for militants joining us now is
toby lanza former u.n secretary general
who was stationed in afghanistan until
june of last year hello to you thank you
for joining us on the program this
morning mr lanza what can we reasonably
expect to be achieved from this meeting
i think it's an important moment for
uh the g20 a group of uh
economically rich countries and
politically influential countries to get
together and to a large extent get
beyond the emotion associated with the
way in which things fell apart in
afghanistan just two months ago and to
focus on some of the key issues which um
confront all of us whether we like it or
not
and those include fight against terror
and ironically we're going to have to
engage with the taliban because at the
moment they are
the only power on the ground in
afghanistan who can confront
isis and it's going to include a
conversation i hope about rights in
particular of women and about
aid and engaging to support the
population there
should the taliban have been invited to
the table
no the taliban have not been invited to
the table and i think that would have
been very unusual and i would never have
expected it but i think that what uh all
the leaders of the g20 need to recognize
now is that without actually stating
that the taliban is a legitimate uh
government per se
for operational reasons there is
every need to engage with the taliban on
a day-to-day basis and i think
increasingly now that's starting to
happen and and that is a good thing if
indeed
uh the united kingdom and other
countries wish to stay engaged in a very
important part of the world remember
that afghanistan
is just south of russia just west of
china east of iran and north of pakistan
and india so this is a crucial part of
the world and the uk and other countries
in the west certainly want to stay
engaged
and to that end uh british politicians
um negotiating certainly meeting with
the taliban yesterday in a neutral
country in the middle east uh
illustrating just how important the
british think it is to have that
dialogue with the taliban the americans
feeling the same way you have obviously
had dealings with the taliban given that
you have worked in the country
previously what's your view
well i dealt with the taliban for over
three years on a very regular basis both
outside the country uh and inside the
country and um i have to say
it and this may sound unusual but it's
it's um a group with whom one can have a
conversation and where there is a
certain amount of clarity i am not
surprised by some of the measures that
the taliban are taking at the moment
including preventing
uh teenage girls from attending school
this is something that none of us want
to see
but we need to engage in a conversation
with the taliban on that type of an
issue and if we stay away we can't so
whether it's britain the united states
or other countries having regular
contact with the taliban both in kabul
eventually and outside the country is
going to be very important especially on
the question of rights but also on aid
which one could see as a certain carrot
if you will
but definitely on this question of
fighting isis which has a local
affiliate in afghanistan which could
eventually create real havoc uh near and
far
but but can the taliban be taken at
their word it would appear
they made a series of promises and
undertakings uh in august and many of
them already falling apart
i think it's important for us to test
their word and not be terribly surprised
when they take measures such as
preventing teenage girls from going to
school but i would say that during my
time in uh kabul in the capital of
afghanistan and i was there for well
over three years
my experience was
that on key issues of security and at
the end of the day
uh our security in britain the security
of of europe at large uh overrides all
else and on key issues the taliban
ironically will now become
a partner for the west uh in this battle
against uh possibly resurgent is uh on
the ground in afghanistan and that needs
to be prevented at all costs so
we will test the taliban at their word
uh on some of these key issues
and the only way to do that is by
engaging in a conversation i would say
that when it comes to aid the taliban
will be desperate for it and i would
never suggest that we start handing over
money to the taliban itself
but supporting key united nations
agencies such as the world food
programme unicef the world health
organization and indeed keen uh aid
agencies such as save the children from
the uk
supporting them to help the people of
afghanistan is going to be very
important 40 million people half of whom
are hungry
half of all children under the age of
five
are suffering from acute malnutrition
you know ignoring afghanistan really
isn't on the cards and we're going to
have to talk to the taliban whether we
like it or not mr lancer thank you very
much indeed for your expertise this
morning we do appreciate it of course
thank you
thank you
coming up in the next hour if you missed
it you'll definitely want to catch our
interview with the government minister
this morning reacting to
a reporter scathing report about the way
that the government dealt with the
pandemic i asked if he wanted to
apologize for unnecessary deaths 11
times 11 times he didn't stay tuned
[Music]